special surprise with a mustache
knowing the amount of effort that goes
on to put on a major league baseball
game people in the truck
watching and seeing that the color of
the grass is this bright green and i've
only seen this as a fan
uh from my basement tatum
oh my gosh the furniture is gonna get
rearranged it's turning on the record
player get out of there
no way get the toucan off your head
no the two that's okay that's a
premonition on
tatum's part that the rockies are gonna
get a w tonight tatum get out of there
go eat your veggies good one
kyle working with tony walters here's
the one two and
another strikeout this time on a slider
that's five out of six matchups
not only one by freeland but one with a
punch out
hard to nolan what a pickup that was a
that was a tough part now it's easy
julio as you mentioned the good start
that he had against houston saturday
gave up just one run but
like a lot of the runs he's given up
this year it came in the first inning
something that he's still trying to
figure out rockies have a great
opportunity
to get on the board early against durias
this ball lined to right taggings hurry
as the catch made by bets here comes
tapia
and he is safe at home plate
what he's done lately doesn't translate
very well to coors field it's been
almost exclusively fastball slurve
usage of that change up has gone down
and down and down
a pop up here muncie's got it for out
number two
trying to come through with two outs and
he will base hit center field
here comes story to the house two to
nothing colorado
as we have said so many times
these first innings this year have been
haunting him
bellard first with two out maria's home
with a 1-2
he pops it up right side of the infield
max muncie will put an end to this first
but the rockies continue
his first inning struggles playing two
and the waves gonna hit that terrific
pitch from freeland
second strikeout one got in the second
seer got a board on an error in his
first at-bat
hitting 301 first pitch lines went to
deep right field and it is
gone a home run
corey seeger his 13th home run of the
year
a laser-like line drive home run
and the dodgers are on the board
colorado two
dodgers one base is loaded two gun
fourth inning freeland to the plate with
another o2
kiki hernandez got hit
and the game is tied at two on an 02
pitch andrew friedman and his crew
actually felt the same way oh two ground
ball to third see if the nugget dirt
talk about the nuggets huh how about the
rockies turning another
five four three good zone play right
there
people down the line that are saying you
know you're really gonna keep trying
this
swings and misses in an elevated
fastball strike three
they think very highly of smith's
leadership skills
see you later so smith is gone
here's the 2-2 to bellinger he's got him
hard slider bellinger didn't have a
chance mookie betts is up there in a
very key situation and he has been a key
ingredient for the dodgers when it comes
to
runners in scoring position and driving
them in that's a line drive base hit to
center field
mookie betts delivers again giving the
dodgers their first lead of the night
rbi single to center field scoring [ __ ]
hernandez and it's 3-2
la rogers leading for the first time as
seeger comes up
seeger lifts the ball to right center
field pallard's going back still on the
move
off the wall corey seeger with another
knock
rios in the score bets held at third on
a seeger double
single double for corey seeger tonight
the dodgers lead
4-2 turner one for threes grounded into
a couple double plays but
singular and scores that kicks by
walters and bets will come in to make it
5-2
on this one one smith pulls it down the
line a fair ball into the left field
corner
seeger can walk home muncie chugging for
third he heads for the plate
he will score on a two-run double from
will
smith a five spot in the seventh for the
dodgers
second and third two gone here's a 3-2
pitch from diaz
taylor takes low and gets to the back
stop here comes will
smith and they have six runs in the
seventh inning
rios hammers this spot a right field a
bullet of a home run
and they grow the lead to 9-2 as rios
hits his second home run of the road
trip
well this is going to be a home run to
deep left field i believe
that's maybe not nope yeah there's you
got deets for a second by hernandez i'm
like what's he doing
things way gone right
fuentes pokes it to right bets is there
and that does it
dodgers cruise in the series opener at
coors coorsfield 9-3
getting six runs in the seven